[Music]
[Applause]
you know standing next to Manu Ginobili
where you're going wow
that's a big difference between those
two
saw this story our good buddy Gilbert
Arenas in this podcast gills Arena
hosted by Underdog fantasy live
basketball show on YouTube where
anything can happen and that's exactly
what happened Zion Williamson showed up
I don't know if he was scheduled to show
up but Gilbert Arenas the former
All-Star co-host of Gil's Arena joining
us on the program how did this come
about that Zion Williamson Just Dropped
In
he just literally dropped in we were um
we're actually talking about him
um we were talking we were talking about
you know the weight and the problems and
having chefs and being an NBA player and
being young and while we're in the
middle of that he's walking past the
window
and then he just like he sees us he's
like yo
excited to come on in okay uh asking
that question about dieting can be a
sensitive topic you know we we find out
if we're fat shaming somebody how much
thought did you give to that of actually
asking him about dieting
no
um you know we're we're athletes
um
it was always a concern of mine with him
um when everyone was talking about 285
he's the Beast and I'm like 285 at 19.
um that's probably going to be a problem
in the NBA because he hasn't touched the
NBA weight he hasn't went through the
NBA schedule where we're doing more
sitting than college right we're
drinking Gatorades we're on planes late
night where we gain pounds uh during the
season I had a problem with that right I
gained 20 I was at 224 I came in at 206
in training camp by January I was 224
and I was freaking out I had to figure
out what am I doing wrong here playing
42 minutes a game
but can you follow LeBron's regimen I
mean you got to be disciplined but
LeBron's figured this out Gilbert
yes he asks um he's very he's very
disciplined he's very self-aware
um
but
he's figured it out later on in his
career you remember there was a time
where LeBron was 285 remember we were
doing comparisons of the first time he
was in the Olympics and we're like you
know he's you know two inches taller
than Karma alone he's the same weight
right he was he was he was on the
heavier side and he had to make that
conscious decision if he wanted to be a
longevity player he had to dial it down
so you know I think Zion now has
realized that you know his biggest his
biggest
um challenge will be
um you know maintaining a good healthy
weight for himself yeah I've said all
along that his biggest opponent is
himself and you know trying to figure
that out you know Charles Barkley went
through this
you know when you're the round mound of
rebound uh in in college and then you
get to the pros you know Moses Malone
kind of had to wake him up do the
Pelicans have somebody who can sort of
grab Zion and say let's go through this
together or you've gotta you've got to
do this if you want to have any kind of
longevity in the NBA
yeah you know at the age and you know I
know some people's like well you're
you're making it easy for him no I'm
trying to make it easy for him and the
easy part is he's gonna need help
because the age that this is not an age
where we're eating salad and kale and
carrots and drinking water but that's
not that age like when we were all 23 24
we were still eating hamburgers so he's
gonna still eat on the healthier side
with steaks and stuff but this is more
lean fish and his body is not ready for
that that you know that is going to be a
Shale shock to him and it's going to be
miserable and to lose weight it can't be
a miserable experience it still has to
be fun for you to stick with that diet
like I'm still having trouble breaking
soda and donuts and cookies here and
there
um so it's one of those things where you
know there has to be a player that's
with him that's helping him along that
has the same problem and it's one of
those two-man tandems
um but you can see that he's really
aware of it and he's he's trying did you
talk about any of the other Social Media
stuff with women with him
no um
and if you if you if if anybody noticed
you have three NBA players there
we didn't even think of
touching that subject because we know if
that was us we wouldn't want that to be
talked about
um this is one of those things where
it was on it was on the Fly moment right
no one expected it but we all had the
same sense of whatever he's going
through personal in his personal life
leave it there let's keep it basketball
related let's keep it to you know what's
really important here right we all have
and made bad decisions when it comes to
the women we choose you know we're all
we're not perfect here
um but that has nothing to do with how
to perform you know you we need you on
that Court to be who you are he's
Gilbert Arenas his podcast is Gil's
Arena and it's uh on Underdog fantasy
Rashad McCants and uh Brendan Jennings
uh Josiah Johnson is uh on that podcast
as well if I said you could have Zion
for the next five years or John Morant
for the next five years
oh man
and and I get to train them
yes because both need some help
yeah
um if I'm if I'm training that means I
can watch you know my asset if his mind
yeah I'll pick Zion
really
yeah because I'll make sure that you
know
um he's on the right track all the time
I'm gonna micromanage
um the asset um I'm gonna make sure that
he has the right people around him he
has the right you know staff even when
he gets home
um but that's the same thing with John
though Gil yeah it's the same you know
the the kids it's
it's gonna get worse poor
the NBA with young players because the
money's going up right so that's more
money you know there was a point where
you know before 95 players can come in
unproven players can come in and sign
you know 40 50 80 million dollar deals
and then in 95 they cut it down and had
rookie salary caps well
now you have like lamelo ball
you know two three years in 260 million
right all of this all of this money is
like giving you know 100 200 300 million
to early frat kid where he's in his
party days right it's kind of dangerous
how would you have done with that kind
of money
oh you see what I did with the money I
had
what's the most money you spent on
something you look back and go what was
I thinking
um
probably Hugh Hefner's uh Grotto pool I
I you know I've you know you hear about
the the The Grotto and I found the guy
who uh did that and I said I wanted but
bigger wait wait you had him replicate
The Grotto at the Playboy Mansion yes
but the problem is I don't have the
Playboy bunny
yeah
uh let's let's play guess how much that
cost
Polly I'll start with you what do you
think that the The Grotto at uh
Gilbert's house Gilbert's Grotto I'm
gonna go 225 Grand
oh I think you would laugh at that
really yeah yeah that's probably just
the furniture Todd what do you think
783 thousand dollars all right Seton
what do you think hold on are we we're
just talking about The Grotto part the
the pool the whole the whole pool dang
man that's crazy
um well I don't want to be insulting
I'm gonna say seventy five thousand
dollars oh you're being insulting yeah
yeah the the the pool skimmer probably
is more than that I'm just going with
the rock formation part that's all yes
75 000 yeah uh Marvin 1.2 I was gonna
say one and a half million dollars
it was about 700. oh 700. okay
good for you oh only 700 000. that
sounds like a bargain that's what I said
75.00
you started off by saying you're kind of
stupid purchase that you made yeah did
you have to run it by were you married
at the time no oh okay
um Dame Lillard has taken away the
bargaining power of the Portland
Trailblazers so how does Portland get
something out of this that they can say
this is a win-win situation like what's
Portland do to say to their fan base we
traded him this we got what we uh we
think will make us better
um it's
it's they both have their bargaining
ships right you know Dame wants out
they're like okay we're gonna Grant it
but we want something back in return
that's fair for you I mean for us too
this is a business so at the end of the
day they don't have to trade them
like we we all assume that
if we don't trade you you're gonna come
back here and do what sit destroy your
your worth it's your worth still right
so um
if you want to be traded for the value
you have you still have to play there's
really you know so it's in it's in
it's easier if we can get them out now
before the season starts so the guys we
have now has the Fresh Start versus you
know taking a backseat the Dame and then
when he leaves you know like you'd
rather give the the Sheldon and Scoot
um the ball from tip-off versus game
starting with it and then handing it off
to him after he leaves what did you
think of Victor one by Yama
um love the skill set
um
you know the adjustment period you know
from you know France to now there's
going to be we're seeing that he's
adjusting game by game
um from now to training camp is going to
be an adjustment from the training camp
uh first preseason game so the opening
game is going to be a different
adjustment too so we're going to see
different levels we're gonna see you
know right now we should just you know
look at the little things he's doing you
know throwing it up re-tipping it back
you know we're gonna see some of those
very great highlights and by January I
think he would be in full motion of what
we should expect
um he said something
very interesting
in um his press conference he said
it's less
physical
which we all assume that coming to
America is more physical for you
not realizing
how he described Euroleague everyone is
on the ground no one's flying so because
everyone's on the ground everyone's
battling there's more pushing there's
more shoving in the NBA everyone's
trying to jump over you run around you
so to him it's less physical for him
than it was when he was overseas who was
the guy that you had to adjust when you
faced him
um because one bayama with that wingspan
you know you don't see too many of those
guys and the ability to be on the
perimeter as well was there a player
where you go oh my God I got to readjust
where my release point is
um I mean when you're driving it was
Shaquille O'Neal
um
um we had uh Yao you know he had to be
um going in that lane versus Yao you
know he's not gonna hit you with the
body but you had to go over you know the
the long arms
carolinko for some reason
well he had he had a pretty good
wingspan yeah he had a pretty good
wingspan and he jumped and it was just
so awkward that you never knew when it
was coming right so those three players
took out the most
yeah I just can't imagine you know when
you're with these guys in a social
setting like Shaq
but to see him on a basketball floor
where there's certain dimensions and you
have to abide by those Dimensions when
you're going down the lane against him I
I would you be more concerned about him
blocking your shot or just knocking you
to the ground
with Shaq knocking you to the ground
because
um half of Shaq's defense was you not
coming in here so that first foul that
Shaq was going to give you was going to
be hurtful right it was going to hurt
and now you're second guessing do you
want to actually go back and catch that
part two so that was part of his his
great defense that he's gonna let you
know what's in here so now you can
second guess with uh Wendy it's gonna be
more just trying to block your shot so
um he's gonna get dunked on a lot
because he's going to give them the
opportunity to try to come in there Shaq
wasn't giving you the opportunity yeah
yeah I never thought of that that Shaq
purposely was going to hit you hard
[Laughter]
yeah so you win one like you know like
guys like Vince you were like oh Vince
is gonna dunk on Shaq he hit you hard
one time
you're like I'll do these floaters in
these jumpers did you ever say anything
to Shaq if he hit you hard
ouch
you never talk back to him no no because
how he hits you know um let's say
someone like Yao or someone like Tim
Duncan trying to come in there the
guards caught the same punishment right
he couldn't control how hard he was
hitting you right so it was like oh that
hurt you know of course please you don't
think he added a little more emphasis
just to make sure that you didn't come
back
yeah no when it came that for that first
foul no matter who came in there yeah um
and it seemed like you know like Derek
Fisher and Kobe will open up for the
drivers he they'll open up the lane for
you to come in there
and you're like oh it looks it looks so
tempting it looks so tempting wait a
minute they were leading you to
slaughter like they're going go ahead go
in there you know
it was part of their strategy so like
somebody like me D Wade LeBron let him
come in here the first time I'll hit him
and then from here
good to talk to you as always thanks for
making time
ah no problem thank you for having me
that's uh Gilbert Arenas